[Music]
welcome back so we're talking about the
singular value decomposition the SVD of
a matrix X and what we've noticed is
that the matrix if we write x equals u
Sigma V transpose the matrices U and V
are unitary matrices unitary matrices
are extremely important in science and
engineering and so I want to tell you a
little bit more about what they mean and
how to interpret them geometrically and
in particular we're also going to think
about the economy size SVD so this is an
N by n u matrix this is an M by n V
matrix but I could also write this as
the economy SVD like this where this is
just the first M columns of U and the
first M by M sub block of Sigma ok so
what we mean by unitary just as a recap
is that essentially u u transpose equals
u transpose u equals an identity matrix
and similarly V V transpose equals V
transpose V equals an identity matrix
and they're different size identity
matrices now if I was using the economy
SVD then only u hat transpose U hat
would equal the identity this one would
not be the identity if I use this this
rectangular u hat matrix okay but u and
V are unitary matrices and essentially
the way I think about this is that
unitary matrices preserve the angles
between any two vectors in the vector
space that they're they're transforming
okay so they preserve angles and lengths
of vectors so unitary transformations
preserve angles between vectors and
lengths of vectors angles and lengths
of vectors okay good
and so other unitary transformations an
example would be the Fourier transform
the Fourier transform is probably the
most famous and widely used unitary
transformation essentially it takes some
vector space and it's a coordinate
transformation into a new representation
it just takes all of those vectors and
rotates them into a new representation
where things become simpler okay but the
angles between two vectors in our
original space remain the same when I
rotate through the Fourier transform and
when I rotate through these unitary
matrices from the singular value
decomposition okay I almost think about
this like constellations in the sky okay
so if you look up at the night sky you
see all of these stars and even though
they rotate across the sky over the
course of the night and the seasons the
the fixed constellations remain the same
the angles between the stars remain the
same that's a unitary transformation as
we travel through the solar system okay
and so essentially these unitary
transformations just rotates vectors
they just rotate vectors but they don't
change the length or the angles between
them okay and so what I mean by this is
if I have any two vectors x and y in my
in my vector space and I take the inner
product of these two vectors it's the
same if I map X through this unitary
matrix U or if I map Y through that
unitary matrix U or if I map both
through that unitary matrix u so this
inner product between x and y is
unchanged sorry this is a big no-no it's
only unchanged if I map both vectors
both vectors through the unit transfer
unitary transformation you very
important sorry but this is true for all
x and y in my vector space for all of my
n-dimensional vectors in my vector space
x and y the inner product between those
two vectors kind of
geometry and where those two vectors are
with respect to each other doesn't
change when I map through you you just
rotates them together okay that's what I
mean by a unitary transformation very
important okay I will note that I have
been using the I've been assuming that
all of my data in this this lecture
series is real valued so that X only has
real numbers and these are real valued
matrices so this is the real matrix
transpose or you take you know a matrix
and you knock it over kind of transpose
it on its side but if we have complex
valued data so if X is complex and we
denote that by it being in the set of
complex numbers complex matrices of N by
M then instead of transpose we use
what's known as the complex conjugate
transpose then we would use X star which
is the complex conjugate transpose this
is just a little aside because in the
book I think we almost entirely use this
notation to be very general in case we
are dealing with complex valued data
whereas in this lecture series I'm going
to deal with real value data primarily
so if our data was complex then all of
these transposes will become stars they
become complex conjugate transpose and
what that means is that in addition to
transposing the matrix we take the
complex conjugate of every single
element now if X is real valued then the
complex conjugate transpose is just the
transpose because the complex conjugate
of a real number is that same real
number okay good and the idea of unitary
transformations is more general and fits
in complex valued vector vector spaces
to you which is why I'm bringing this up
okay good so unitary transformations
just rotate your vector space so that
angles and lengths are preserved and
that means that the basic geometric
structure so if you think of faces in
the vector space
images you want to preserve angles and
lengths because that's how you tell
person a from person be like that's very
very important is understanding the
geometry how these vectors are related
in that vector space so it's it's key
that these unitary transformations
encode that information okay now there's
a geometric perspective that I also
really like to take and I'm going to
draw here which is if we think of our
matrix X and I'm going to draw it as
again a tall skinny matrix here it can
multiply vectors on the right or on the
left it can multiply these little kind
of V vectors on the right or it can
multiply these long kind of U transpose
vectors on the left and if I'm if I map
x times V I'm going to get something
that's taller and if I that taller than
V and if I map X times this u transpose
I'm gonna get something that's shorter
out then then you okay and so you can
think of this interesting geometric
interpretation of what this matrix X
does in terms of these unitary
transformations so let's say I have a
sphere of all possible points in the
vector space are n in kind of my column
space of X this is a sphere of unit
length of all unit length vectors in RN
and let's let's give this thing a little
vector name sorry this is our M R M the
the set of all vectors in the row space
of X and I'm going to call this little
vector V okay now if I multiply all of
these vectors V by my X matrix so I map
all of these x times V then for all of
those little V matrices I'm gonna get at
all u vector out the size of the column
of X and so I'm gonna map into an
n-dimensional space by multiplying all
of these by X and that's going to sweep
this large ellipsoid I didn't draw the
best ellipsoid in the world but it's a
large ellipsoid the sphere if you
multiply it by X on the Left maps into
an ellipsoid and the lengths of these
principal axes are specifically given by
the singular values of x so this long
length these directions stretch there
are directions here that stretch through
X and there are some directions that get
smashed and and compacted through X and
the orientation of this ellipsoid is
somehow given by this the left singular
vectors of X so those left singular
vectors in you can represent kind of the
orientation of this ellipsoid and the
singular values tell me how they're
going to be elongated or squished okay
I'm being a little bit vague here
because I'm gonna code this up in a
little bit and we're gonna actually work
through all of the nuts and bolts of
computing this make this sphere and
mapping it through X computing this
ellipsoid so you're gonna get the
quantitative picture of this soon but I
just want you to think this matrix X can
multiply vectors on the right or vectors
on the left and that corresponds to a
change to a rotation of space okay now
remember U is unitary and doesn't change
the lengths or angles of things but X
itself is not unitary and so that's why
this gets deformed and stretched now
similarly if I take the set of unit
vectors in r n I can multiply those on
the Left these little u times X's and I
get another elongated ellipsoid in my V
space in my n-dimensional space and
again these the orientation of this
ellipsoid will now be determined by
these singular vectors by that rotation
and the elongation will again still be
given by the same singular values okay
so they'll have the same rough extents
and the last point I want to make is
that again this X matrix doesn't have to
be square so if it's rectangular these
spaces don't have
the same dimension so let's give a
concrete example let's say that X is
like a two by three matrix then if I
have my three dimensional sphere in RM
and I map it through this X matrix then
it maps down to a two dimensional space
so there's an ellipsoid in two
dimensions in in my two dimensional u
space okay so these don't have to have
the same dimension but I just want you
to kind of be aware of the geometric
interpretation of the singular value
decomposition these unitary matrices are
very very powerful again they're kind of
the data-driven generalization of
Fourier transform matrices that rotate a
coordinate transformation of your data
into another coordinate system where
things might become simpler okay in
terms of these principle directions that
explain most of the variance of the
column space or the row space okay so
will code this up and we'll see how this
actually works in software and that will
give you a little bit more of a
quantitative picture of how these these
geometric transformations work okay
thank you